connaissez-vous la légende de titan un
homme qui a obtenu 2 l'immortalité afin
que lui et sa ds puisse aimer
éternellement malheureusement dans la
demande faite aux dieux il ya eu un
oubli avec l'âge le corps de l'homme
commence à se fripe et se tasser se
rabougrir crois que c'est du respect
savent y était sans fin mais pas sa
jeunesse il a ds qui elle gardait les
traits de ses 20 ans finit par se
dégoûter de cet homme très moche qui
reste au fond pitoyablement mortels
l'histoire est triste mais grâce à la
science on pas pouvoir en changer la fin
ces dernières années les chercheurs ont
fait des découvertes déterminante sur
pourquoi nous vieillissons des
traitements sont en cours si bien qu'on
puisse considérer la vieillesse comme
une maladie on soignera est-ce que le
premier homme qui aura la jeunesse
éternelle est déjà n'est peut-être que
ça sera vont vieillir ça fait quoi dans
ton corps ton organisme se renouvellent
en permanence donc toi d'il ya 15 ans
n'a plus que quelques cellules en commun
avec la personne que tu étais elles ont
presque toutes été changés renouvelé au
fond ça veut dire que ton corps est plus
jeune que toi puisqu'il a moins de 15
ans mais du coup pourquoi notre corps
s'épuise s'il se renouvelle et bien
c'est justement ça le problème quand vos
cellules se divisent elles font une
copie de l'adn mais cet adn à un nombre
de divisions limité et ce à cause des
télomères ce sont des petits morceaux
non codants à l'extrémité de l'adn un
peu comme des gaines de protection qui
l'empêchent de s'effilocher
sauf qu'à chaque copie ben c'est guen
sabine et c'est la première cause
importante du vieillissement vos
télomères rétrécissent trop la cellule
va alors interprété ça comme une
corruption est entré en sénescence elles
deviennent sorte de cellule zombies qui
reste dans ton corps mais qui ne remplit
plus son rôle habituel voire même et
n'importe quoi aux cheveux tondre votre
peau se ride des poils poussent là où il
faut pas bref vous partez en cacahuète
et ça va s'accélérer parce qu'une
cellules sénescentes a tendance à
contaminer ses voisines en libérant des
molécules inflammatoires deuxième cause
importante du vieillissement votre stock
de cellules souches diminuent ce sont
les cellules ultime de votre corps
capables de donner n'importe quel type
de cellules chez l'embryon et les
cellules souches construisent le corps
chez l'adulte elles vont réparer
certaines lésions à caractéristiques de
ces cellules souches et qu'elles ne sont
pas touchés par la réduction des
télomères puisqu'elles ont en elles de
la télomérase qui va réparer les boudent
adn ça paraît cool mais c'est dangereux
si la télomérase réparé à l'infiniment
cellules souches défectueuse zad via une
tumeur donc avec le temps le corp ans à
moi en produire et donc moins se réparer
bien sûr il ya d'autres raisons qui
explique votre vieillissement c'est ce
que vous voyez à l'écran si on arrive à
guérir chacun de ces points alors le
vieillissement n'est plus et dans le
domaine ya une molécule très prometteuse
matte ont découvert une molécule qui
arrêtera le vieillissement voici le
docteur sinclair voulu donner 35 ans en
réalité il a dépassé les 50 professeur
de génétique à harvard il est peut-être
celui qui nous rajeunir à tous ces
recherches commencent il ya 20 ans avec
du vin rouge plus exactement une
molécule qui est résident le resvératrol
c'est un polyphénol produit par le
raisin stressé quand il fait trop chaud
qu'il ne pleut pas c'est quand il ya des
conditions difficiles or il se trouve
que le stress du raisin semble rallonger
leur durée de vie mais aussi celle des
souris obèses et des levures alors il
essaie de comprendre pourquoi étudie la
biochimie du vieillissement il découvre
des interactions avec une molécule aux
propriétés encore plus intéressante le
nmnm nicotinamide mononucléose id une
forme modifiée de la vitamine b3 il a
injecté du hem nn dans les souris et
quelque chose des tranchées produits les
vieilles souris péter la forme à la
course elle explose les records des plus
jeunes comme si un mec de 70 ans tu
mettais la raclée sur le terrain leurs
poils gris et des garniers ont repoussé
leur cellule vieillissante se sont
réparés au bout d'une semaine de
traitement il devenait impossible de
différencier leurs cellules de celle
d'une soirée juvénile alan récemment on
a commencé à faire des tests sur l'homme
et même si on n'a pas encore les données
sur le long terme on note déjà deux
meilleures performances sportives une
baisse des graisses dans le foie du taux
de sucre sanguin amélioration de
l'audition ou des fonctions cardiaques
que du positif
mais comment ça marche accrochez vous
il y aura beaucoup de molécules cité
parce que dans le corps tout est
question d'interaction et de réaction en
chaîne en fait le nmm va avoir un effet
direct sur la production de n avait plus
une molécule que nous produisons nous
mêmes et qui joue un rôle essentiel dans
nos cellules selanne a déplu ce qui
donne de l'énergie qui limite les
réactions inflammatoires qui répare
l'adn qui ralentit la réduction des
télomères et c'est même l'ingrédient
principal des sirtuines disant sim qui
régule le vieillissement ouais je sais
ça fait beaucoup de choses à retenir
dites-vous juste que l' ena des plus
sert à fabriquer toutes les solutions
aux problèmes de vos cellules en avoir à
profusion serait-il la clip pour rester
éternellement en bonne santé le problème
c'est que vous en avez moins en
vieillissant une des causes identifiées
c'est l'augmentation de l'enzyme cédé 38
qui va manger là n'avait plus produit
dans notre corps pourquoi la cd 38
augmente à cause de la sénescence de vos
cellules ouais c'est le serpent qui se
mord la queue une première solution
serait de désactiver le cd 38 mais
langil est impliquée dans la réponse
immunitaire la désactiver ces se rendre
plus sensible aux maladies une deuxième
solution serait d'agir sur notre niveau
de haine a déplu malheureusement j'ai
plein de raisin stressé ego bd jules
dehaene à des plus ça marche pas trop le
but c'est que ces substances entre dans
vos cellules or la digestion les
transforme regardez le schéma du mnm tu
mets une molécule dans le corps elle se
transforme des dizaines de foire avec
des conséquences en cascade c'est très
difficile de savoir ce que tu as au bout
du compte et ce qui bloque le résultat
escompté et vous savez le pire augmenter
le henan et plus ce n'est pas suffisant
il manque quelque chose avec quoi
faut-il combiner le n ad plus le n a
déplu ce n'est que la moitié de la
solution contre le vieillissement il
faut l'associer à autre chose comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure le n ad plus
serap plein de choses dans la cellule
c'est notamment l'ingrédient central
dans la production des sirtuines selon
wikipedia se sont d'aider à sept-îles
has ena des plus dépendants plus
simplement ce qui nous intéresse nous
c'est leur rôle dans le ralentissement
de l'apoptose et de la sénescence vous
trouverez dans cette revue scientifique
qui les associe aux gènes de la halle
j'ai vite et on a donc besoin de deux
choses produire plus de signal et plus
ça c'est bon on sait faire mais aussi
augmenter sa production de circuits et
comment on fait ça notre adn va produire
c'est sur twin quand on est un peu comme
ce raisin stressé dont on parlait tout à
l'heure manque de nourriture manque
d'oxygène fatigue du corps après
l'effort le froid bref quand le corps
passe en mode survie qu'il se protège
dans ces moments là la cellule devient
très rustique équipés pour la longévité
on a testé sur des souris en leur
enlevant les gènes codant les sirtuines
et effectivement elle vieillit c'est
plus vite a contrario on a ajouté à
l'adn d'autres sourient les sirtuines
d'autres espèces à la longévité
exceptionnelle et magie elles vivaient
plus longtemps c'est sirtuines vous
pouvez désactiver en vivant comme un
gourou sont et instagram ou en utilisant
la science c'est à dire en prenant des
molécules qui vont activer
artificiellement les sirtuines il ya le
resvératrol dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure avec le raisin mais on en a
trouvé plein d'autres qui ont tous fait
l'objet d'études sérieuses notamment sur
leur pouvoir cénobitique leur capacité à
détruire les cellules sénescentes dont
on parlait au début c'est cool mais rien
de miraculeux derrière ces noms
compliqués tous des polyphénols qu'on
trouve dans certains fruits et légumes
ouais c'est un peu décevant prendre des
boosters de l'année des plus faire des
jeunes et manger des légumes c'est pas
la conclusion vous attendez d'une vidéo
de sciences vous dirait du thierry
casasnovas ce et si c'était le seul
problème le danger des remèdes contre le
vieillissement et si ce dont on vient de
parler était cancérigène parce qu'ils
étaient des cellules à vivre plus
longtemps c'est aussi aider les tumeurs
en faire de même vous a parlé de la
télomérase tout alors on a pensé pendant
longtemps que ça serait la solution anti
vieillissement jusqu'à ce qu'on se rende
compte que c'était hautement cancérigène
les cellules souches pareil on a aussi
pensé que c'était miraculeux donc des
personnes se sont injectés dans les
paupières pour diminuer leurs rides et
au lieu de les rajeunir des eaux ont
commencé à y pousser un deuxième
problème qui a été remarqué c'est que le
surplus de haine à des plus d'approché
dans vos réserves de groupe mais thil et
augmenter votre taux d'homocystéine pour
le dire plus simplement réduire votre
espérance de vie voilà pourquoi il faut
compléter ce avec une prise importante
de 8 b et oblige à prendre de nouveaux
compléments mais ça s'arrête quand même
sinclair ne s'est pas totalement ce
qu'il fait partage sur internet les
produits qu'il expérimente sur lui-même
ce qui inclut des médicaments
accessibles uniquement sur ordonnance
par exemple la metformine contre le
diabète et des statines contre le
cholestérol pourquoi parce que des
études montrent leur efficacité sur la
production de sirtuines et donc leur
allongement de la vie sauf que plein de
gens essaient d'imiter ce que fait
sinclair et vous devinez les problèmes
acheter des médicaments de pharmacie sur
le dark web pour se les gober tout seul
sans suivi médical c'est en cause faire
très mal malheureusement avec des
résultats qui permettent de rallonger la
jeunesse ça attire les vautours
le marché mondial de l'anti âge ses 59
milliards de dollars par an ça donne
envie de prendre sa part du gâteau et
capsules bidons sont vendus hors de prix
ya de grandes chances que vous achetiez
60 euros du purs placebos attendez que
des études prouvent que c'est efficace
et sans danger vous avez cet excellent
site qui répertorie toutes les pistes
pour combattre le vieillissement et
l'état des recherches sur le sujet je
vais ça de près mais ne prenez rien de
ce dont on a parlé aujourd'hui avant que
la science conclu et surtout ne rêvez
pas trop tout ça ne va pas vous rendre
immortel sur les souris on parle de 15 à
30% de longévité en plus c'est bien mais
ça n'a pas d'effet sur leur durée de vie
maximale dans le meilleur des cas chez
l'homme on pourrait vivre entre 100 et
120 en plutôt bonne santé on va mourir
quand-même est ton ou obligés de
vieillir vieillir c'est bien c'est
naturel pourquoi la démesure de l'homme
peut-il lutter contre mère nature à la
société moderne oui mais non le
vieillissement toutes les
caractéristiques d'une maladie et on
doit pouvoir la guérir qui plaît dans ce
fléau c'est qu'il est égalitaire jeff
bezos ce un jour sera vieux souffrira et
finira par mourir alors que si sinclair
met en place son traitement les
milliardaires seront les premiers à
pouvoir se l'acheter et nouba on va
continuer à mourir en salle et à la
vieillesse deviendra la maladie des
pauvres et ça pour nous grands singes au
gène égoïste à la jalousie maladive
ayant inventé légalité comme morale pour
calmer l'envi et le ressentiment par
l'exercice d'une violence légitime et
c'est insupportable
mais n'oubliez pas ces recherches
permettront aussi de guérir des maladies
notamment la progéria une maladie
génétique qui accélère le vieillissement
du corps cette jeune fille qui avait
fait sensation sur internet avait 16 ans
pourtant c'était le maire était aussi
court qu'une personne de 90 ans une des
pistes explorées pour guérir ces
maladies donne dans le mille simuler la
réparation des télomères et on revient
au sujet de cette vidéo aussi pour en
revenir au sujet de jeff bezos ce at il
le droit de vivre plus longtemps que les
autres avec le temps les traitements
contre le vieillissement se
démocratiseront en trouvera des règles
pour que ça se passe bien comme on l'a
toujours fait dès qu'il ya eu une
innovation les ordinateurs les
téléphones portables étaient réservés à
une élite fut un temps l'accès à la
longue vie suit aura la même mécanique
sociale évidemment on pourrait
s'inquiéter d'une surpopulation mais on
finira par trouver des solutions en
régulant les naissances ou en colonisant
de nouveaux territoires et après vous
inquiétez pas on va continuer de mourir
même si on élimine les cancers les
maladies et toutes les morts biologique
classique il reste toujours les
accidents de voiture d'armes à feu les
attaques de chiens d'être coiffeur
statistiquement la durée de vie moyenne
d'un humain immortel serait de 9000 ans
dans cet intervalle il finira forcément
par avoir un accident le seul problème
que tous apposé philosophique attention
c'est un peu bad ans qu'en est il de
notre identité en 9000 en vos capacités
cognitives ont changé aux neurones de
mémoire et en nombre limité vos
souvenirs aussi à partir d'un certain
temps vous aurez tout simplement oublié
qui vous est il y a neuf mille ans le
visage de vos parents cette fois là où
vous couriez dans les champs enfants
avec votre amour de jeunesse tout ça
disparaîtra dans l'éternité du temps ton
corps deviendra peut-être immortels mais
ton esprit ne transcendera jamais
l'irrémédiable
[Musique]